ça je passe tu connaisses et des loups
face et les éponges là qu'on trouve soit
dans les magasins bio qui sont des
formes de forme cylindrique et souvent
il ya 3 3 crelot mieux ça c'est utile
aussi pour se gratter le dos et en fait
ça pousse comme ça c'est une courge et
donc au bout d'un moment elle va aller à
sécher et donc c'est plutôt cool parce
que là on approche de l'autonomie en
éponge
[Musique]
donc là c'est la parabole solaire une
parabole qui est rafraîchissante et du
coup tous les rayons de soleil sont
concentrés sur la partie centrale en
train de faire de la compote de pommes
j'ai passé trente ans
c'est vraiment en train d en train de
frémir quoi donc c'est vraiment une un
pouvoir de chauffe qui est pas
négligeable quand on fait bouillir 5
litres d'eau en 20 minutes quand ça tape
bien qu il est 15h quoi
là aujourd'hui on est plutôt sur un
modèle où la ferme c'est un lieu de vie
et après nous on tire nos revenus de
l'extérieur donc par exemple moi je suis
auteur j'écris des livres je fais de la
photo aussi donc c'est ça m'est revenue
il ya un autre qui fait des rénovations
écologiques de logements donc c'est
encore une fois à l'extérieur l'idée
c'était de mutualiser beaucoup de tâches
je peux pas faire la cuisine en commun
la visite tout dans la maison etc ça
permet de faire des économies d'échelle
en fait qui libère du temps il ya aussi
l'idée qu'on puisse se remplacer les uns
les autres
[Applaudissements]
du coup le but du lieu ici c'est la
sobriété donc d'avoir l'interminable sur
la trame du roman est donc on essaie de
limiter les utilisations du pétrole au
maximum on a 23 mètres carrés de
panneaux solaires là et on a un système
on est en solaire autonome c'est-à-dire
que constate l'énergie dans des
batteries et on est du coup déconnectés
du réseau classique
c'est la première fois que cette
passerelle est testée
j'espère donc qu'elle tient ou quelqu'un
nous resterons en vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc là c'est le panneau électrique il
ya un code couleur selon le niveau de
charge des batteries on va
pouvoir utiliser ou pas
certaines choses par exemple ce qui est
de cette couleur-là l'envers les jaunes
ces choses qui sont pas forcément
essentiel et donc si on est en dessous
de 90 % de charge des batteries on est
un set cette partie là si on en tout 70
voilà c'est le scénario on à la bougie
mais ça nous est jamais arrivé puisqu'on
et c'est bien dimensionné
le but donc à l'époque ça pour vous
changer mais c'est d'avoir un lieu de
vie le plus écologique possible arrivée
à avoir une empreinte écologique la plus
faible possible
et on se dit que à plusieurs c'est plus
facile qu'on peut mettre
plus de choses en place et
les questions des fondements sont venus
bien plus tard on se dit que les choses
vont manifestement que se dégrader
notamment pour les gens qui veulent
rester dans le système
et donc bah nous on essaie de développer
une certaine résilience ici à la ferme
d'un point de vue de de l'autonomie de
nos systèmes électriques la flotte tout
ça on peut considérer qu'on n'est
absolument pas prêt pour un gros
effondrements
traiterait qui serait très brusque mais
sans n'y crois pas mais en fait on s'est
aperçu que d'un autre préparation qui
est donc progressive en 2020 en fait on
était prêt pour ce qui passait pour ce
qui s'est passé en 2020 c'est à dire une
pandémie mondiale et tout le monde qui
sous des masses et c'est à nous ici on a
été quasiment pas affectée
si tu mets une petite
l'a donc avec les huit cent mille mètres
carrés qu'on en culture on a des légumes
pour gérer deux tiers de l'année trois
quarts et si on joue on est grand on
devrait être autonome en légumes ce qui
n'est pas
l'autonomie alimentaire faut pas
confondre parce que en fait on mange
beaucoup de céréales aussi parfois de la
vie en médecine on est plutôt
flexitariens voir végétarien
l'autonomie alimentaire totale ça ne
nous intéresse pas spécialement parce
que nous notre modèle idéal serait
plutôt un système où il ya tout le monde
chaque ferme qui produira pas un
excédent et puis ensuite on s'échange
les denrées quoi comme ça que ça
fonctionne et dans l'est dans les
villages depuis toujours nous le tard si
ça nous intéresse pas parce qu'il ya
aussi un côté assez
finalement d'isolement social quoi si on
produit tout chez nous on n'a plus
besoin les autres et ça c'est hyper
triste parce que là bas on n'a pas tous
les interactions sociales qui font la
richesse de la vie quoi
là c'est un peu le nouveau défi de
s'implanter plus sur le territoire et de
regarder vers les voisins quoi pour pour
créer un truc ensemble c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que de faire avancer les
choses vite sur une ferme en étant tous
plus ou moins d'accord si on veut aller
voir nos voisins pour créer de la
résidence et tout ça avec des gens
différents mais du coup il ya un vrai
défi sur la question de l'altérité quoi
comment est ce qu'on arrive à faire
société avec des gens qui sont fans de
motocross alors que nous on est gentil
pétrole et envoie le challenge iaaf